you're correct i pulled you over because
you're a murderer yes i started to
record because you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving i was recording you
can you call your supervisor please i
already did he's on his way
because you're a murderer okay do you
have that pictured man made me think you
were gonna murder me
okay well i'm sorry you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
okay thank you and i'm perfectly legal
and i'm a teacher so there
congratulations
you're a murderer okay now quick thing
here
one typically a thing that you cannot
say to murderers and get away with being
alive is is you are a murderer right
things that people never said to charles
manson
right hey i'm sorry that's such an
absurd
i'm a teacher i give flying